Democrats called for justice Cavanaugh's
impeachment over another vague
allegations Oh Biden slugs it out with
the media over ace and run targets Saudi
Arabia I'm live from New York this is
the Ben Shapiro show
oh yes we have tons to get you Tammy a
lot of news happening over the weekend
Catherine awful revenge we get another
round of this routine because the New
York Times doing amazing journalistic
work and uncovering another story about
Brett Kavanaugh penis very very
important stuff
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
there seems to be an awful lot of
economic insecurity and a lot of that
economic insecurity is driven by the
fact that we don't know what the central
banks are going to do and sometimes you
have the central bank's talking about
lowering interest rates sometimes you
have them talking about increasing
interest rates and all of that is having
an impact on the value of the dollar and
the value of other currencies well one
of the ways that you can hedge against
central bank manipulation of currency is
to actually invest in crypto or
blockchain currencies last week China
devalued its currency and markets tanked
one consequence was that Bitcoin prices
rose it's time to seriously consider
including some crypto in your portfolio
the best place to trade crypto is eToro
eToro is smart crypto trading made easy
eToro social trading platform has over
11 million traders in facility and
facilitates over 1 trillion dollars in
trading volume per year globally you can
access the world's best crypto
currencies they've got 15 different
coins available with low and transparent
fees you can try before you trade with a
virtual portfolio with $100,000 budgets
you can see if this thing is for you
never miss a trading trend with charts
and pricing alerts sign up today at
eToro comm slash Shapiro that's ET o ro
comm slash repair I know Bitcoin sounds
scary the fact is all it really is is a
blockchain protected currency that isn't
manipulable by central banks go check
them out today at eToro comm slash
Shapiro ET Oro comm slash Shapiro ok so
the big story of the day is that the New
York Times has a brand new breaking
allegation against Brett Kavanaugh you
know the Supreme Court justice and we
just did this like a year ago a year ago
as you recall Judd then judge Brett
Kavanaugh was on his way to confirmation
on the Supreme Court when suddenly there
was an allegation brought forward by
Dianne Feinstein Senator Dianne
Feinstein
and it was leaked out and the allegation
was from Christine Blasi Ford that Brett
Kavanaugh had allegedly held her down
and tried to rape her back when he was
17 years old there was no collaborate
and that there was no any sort of
evidence there there was there was
nothing that corroborated there's no
corroborate of evidence there was no
hard evidence she couldn't name the time
she couldn't
couldn't in the place it didn't matter
this turned into a massive massive story
and then the media started trying to dig
up other allegations of sexual
impropriety by Brett Kavanaugh all from
when he was very young
no Brett Kavanaugh is is nearing 60s and
has mid-50s all of this stuff supposedly
happened back when he was in high school
or at Yale none of the allegations were
corroborated none of them were backed up
and none of them provided any material
evidence for the allegations well now
the New York Times is back because
there's a brand new book out about Brett
Kavanaugh it's it's called the education
of Brett Kavanaugh an investigation from
Robin Pogrebin and Kate Kelly who are
reporters with The Times and authors of
that book now they had a piece in the
New York Times in their news analysis
sections and not in their news section
because that would actually require some
news their news analysis section which
allows them to basically pass off non
news as an op-ed and they bring forward
a new allegation now the problem is the
allegation is exceedingly vague well let
me read you what they have to say in the
New York Times first of all this story
is framed not in terms of news about
another allegation against Brett
Kavanaugh instead it is framed as a
story of victimhood about Deborah
Ramirez
now you remember temporal meristem
Ramirez is the lady who claims that
Brett Kavanaugh supposedly at some sort
of party waved his penis in her face at
Yale there's only one problem is
originally reported by The New Yorker by
Ronan Farrell and Jane Mayer and the
story has not only no corroboration it
has no supporting evidence whatsoever
they're they're a bunch of questions
about that original story
for example in the story itself it says
The New Yorker has not confirmed with
other eyewitnesses that Cavanaugh was
even present at the party where Ramirez
claims he was the magazine contacted
several dozen classmates of Ramirez and
Cavanaugh regarding the incident many
did not respond to interview requests
others declined to comment or said they
did not attend or remember the party the
New York Times also could not find a
single witness to back up her
allegations
The Times quote had interviewed several
dozen people over the past week in an
attempt to corroborate her story and
could find no one with first-hand
knowledge in The New Yorker story
Farrell and Mayer provided a quote from
one of the main men named by Ramirez as
somebody who was apparently there one of
the male classmates who Ramirez said
egged on Cavanaugh denied any memory of
the party
I don't think Brett
/ himself to Debbie or anyone for that
matter that's why he thought Ramirez was
making the allegation he responded I
have no idea a third person Ramirez
cleanses at the party says she was not
there for the alleged incident Ramirez
apparently contacted her former
classmates asking about the incident and
she admitted that she wasn't even sure
that Cavanaugh was the male who exposed
himself
Ramirez quote herself contacted former
Yale classmates asking if they were
called the incident and told some of
them she could not be certain mr.
Cavanaugh was the one who exposed
himself buried 1,700 words into the
original New Yorker piece the report
says a former friend who says she was
best friends with Ramirez says Ramirez
never mentioned the story the former
friend who was married to the male
classmate alleged to be involved and who
signed the statement said of Ramirez
this is a woman I was best friends with
we shared intimate details of our lives
I was never told this story by her or by
anyone else it never came up I didn't
see it I never heard of it happening
Ramirez wasn't even sure her memory was
correct this was the most damning part
of that original New Yorker story the
outlet reported quote in her initial
conversations with the New Yorker
Ramirez was reluctant to characterize
Cavanaugh's role in the alleged incident
with certainty after six days of
carefully assessing her memories and
consulting with her attorney
Ramirez said she felt confident enough
of her recollect recollections to say
she remembers Kavanagh okay if you have
to take six days to assess your memories
and consult with your attorney I'm going
to say you don't have the requisite
level of certainty to make an allegation
like that I said this at the time
everybody else said this at the time
because of course that is ridiculous if
you were making an allegation that
somebody at a party came up to you
expose themselves thrust their penis in
your face pretty good shot you're gonna
remember who that person was right but
apparently and Brett Kavanaugh was
apparently fairly well known on campus
by Ramirez wasn't even clear in her own
mind and then she talked with her
attorney and after six days of
militating about it finally she came out
with the story okay so that is all the
backdrop to today's report in the New
York Times by Pope Urban and Kelly for
trying to sell this book the education
of Brett Kavanaugh and again this thing
is painted not as a new revelation about
Brett Kavanaugh it is painted instead as
Ramirez she just was not socially
accepted the way Brett Kavanaugh was as
though it is some sort of sin to be from
an upper class or upper middle class
background and go to Yale as opposed to
being from a poorer background and going
to Yale last I checked that was not the
allegation
hence Brett Kavanaugh nor is that he
disqualifying allegation for the Supreme
Court if we ruled out everyone who grew
up fairly wealthy in the United States
from sitting on a federal court you can
wipe out two-thirds of the federal bench
they say here's what the New York Times
story says Debra Ramirez had the grades
to go to Yale in 1983 but she wasn't
prepared for what she'd find there a top
student in southwestern Connecticut she
studied hard but socialized little she
was raised Catholic and had a sheltered
upbringing in the summers she worked in
Carvel dishing ice cream commuting in
the $500 car she brought with
babysitting earnings at Yale she
encountered students from more worldly
backgrounds first of all it doesn't
sound like she was impoverished right I
mean she apparently was raised in
southwestern Connecticut not known for
being the poorest area in America she
worked at Carvel dishing ice cream she
was able to buy a car with babysitting
earnings in any case that's not to say
that her background is rich but this
doesn't sound like somebody who was
growing up in the inner city okay in any
case the New York Times has at Yale she
encountered students from more worldly
backgrounds many were affluent and had
attended elite private high schools they
also had experience with drinking and
sexual behavior than miss Ramirez who
had not intended to be intimate with a
man until her wedding night left during
the winter of her freshman year a
drunken dormitory party unsettled her
deeply she and some classmates had been
drinking heavily when she says a
freshman named Brett Kavanaugh pulled
down his pants and thrust his penis at
her prompting her to swat it away and
inadvertently touch it some of the
onlookers who had been faking who had
been passing around a fake penis earlier
in the evening laughed - Ramirez it
wasn't funny at all
it was the nadir of her first year when
she often felt insufficiently rich
experienced or savvy to mingle with her
more privileged classmates okay so a few
things about this number one she was
apparently voluntarily the drunken
dormitory party that would not excuse
sexual assault in any case but if the
idea here is that Brett Kavanaugh and
his colleagues corrupted Ramirez I'm not
seeing the evidence of that because
again putting aside the alleged incident
she was at a dormitory party heavily
drinking according to her own admission
before she met Kavanagh
so that's not Cavanaugh's fault but the
allegation here is reported with with
basically no countervailing evidence
right she and some classmates had been
drinking heavily when she says a
freshman named Brett Kavanaugh etc etc
now I just pointed out to you all of the
problems with her story
they originally mentioned at the time so
there's nothing new in the story so far
but this is now being presented as a
case of fact I had gone through high
school I'm the good girl and now and one
evening it was all ripped away she said
in an interview earlier this year and
her Boulder Colorado home by preying
upon her in this way she added mr.
Cavanaugh and his friends made it clear
I'm not smart okay now again she took
six days to figure out whether it was
Cavanaugh there's no corroborating
witnesses none at this apparently well
attended dorm dorm party where
everybody's drunk Cavanaugh denies the
claims obviously miss Ramirez his story
would seem far less damaging to
Cavanaugh's reputation than those of dr.
Christine Blasi Ford who claimed the
Kavanagh pinned her to a bed groped her
and tried to remove her clothes while
covering her mouth but while we found
dr. Ford allegations credible during a
10-month investigation mr. Ramirez's
story could be more fully corroborated
at least seven people including miss
Ramirez his mother heard about the Yale
incident long before Cavanaugh was a
federal judge two of those people were
classmates who learned of it just days
after the party occurred suggesting it
was discussed among students at the time
okay but none of those people came
forward to the New Yorker to say
indisputably the Cavanaugh did it or
that she had said that Cavanaugh did it
or who the person was who did this thing
and then we get to the new allegation
okay that's all the old stuff then we
get to the new allegation in the new
york times so here's the new allegation
quote we also uncovered a previously
unreported story about mr. Cavanaugh in
his freshman year that echoes miss
Ramirez his allegation a classmate max
tire saw mr. Cavanaugh with his pants
down at a different drunken dorm party
where friends pushed his penis into the
hand of a female student apparently this
is the most well trafficked penis in the
history of Yale and not only is
Cavanaugh thrusting it in people's faces
according to these allegations now his
friends are apparently grabbing his junk
and pushing them into other people's
hands so basically it's a FedEx package
at this point mr. steyr who runs a
nonprofit organization in Washington
notified senators in the FBI about this
account but the FBI did not investigate
and steyr has declined to discuss it
publicly well if he declines to offer
any details that are worth investigating
then what the hell is this supposed to
mean here okay so the original story
does not include the following line okay
the original story said we corroborated
the story with two officials who have
communicated with mr. steyr the female
student declined to be interviewed that
is where the sentence originally ended
and that is where the sentence
originally ended then much later the New
York Times has to come forward with a
correction and their correction says
quote friends say she does not recall
the episode now it seems to me that
number one if you're Ramirez and
somebody thrust their penis in your face
at a party and it was devastating you
would remember who the person was but
beyond that and that somebody else in
the party could corroborate it but
beyond that the female student in this
story says she does not remember the
incident okay and the New York Times
didn't rigidly include that originally
that wasn't in the story that's pretty
major revision right the update included
the significant detail that several
friends of the alleged victim said she
did not recall the purported sexual
assault in question at all
The Times also stated for the first time
that the alleged victim refused to be
interviewed and has made no comment
about the episode that's an amazing
update right the editors note they added
an editor's note to this story which
basically destroys the entire story it
says an earlier version of this article
which was adapted from a forthcoming
book did not include one elements of the
books account regarding an assertion by
a Yale classmate that friends of Brett
Kavanaugh pushed his penis into the hand
of a female student at a drunken dorm
party the book reports that the female
student declined to be interviewed and
friends say she does not recall the
incident that information has been added
to the article why was it left out of
the article really I mean that's a
pretty serious point isn't it it was in
the book it wasn't in the article why
wasn't it in the article if I say to you
there's an allegation that you murdered
someone and then it also says in the
book that the supposed murder victim is
walking around Fifth Avenue that might
be relevant leaving out the actual
relevant part of the story would be a
pretty massive piece of battery by the
New York Times it's always very weird on
people that say that there's no media
bias why is it that every mistake is in
one direction why why is it that every
single error is in one direction over at
the New York Times this is amazing in
one second we'll see how Democrats
reacted to the original allegation
because this shows how deeply cynical
the original Cavanaugh allegations were
and were treated by the Democrats now I
was willing to go back and listen to the
tape I was willing
to give all sorts of credibility to
Christina Blasi for and then it turns
out she couldn't name where when what
she couldn't name a single person there
could corroborate her story and it
became clear that she had nothing that
the story had fallen apart that there
really was nothing there or at the very
least there was nothing that we could
corroborate so maybe the story was true
but if we can't corroborate it in any
way there is this idea of due process
and innocent until proven guilty if I
allege that you raped puppies in your
backyard and offer no supporting details
you should probably take that with a
grain of salt okay now we have Deborah
Ramirez whose story originally was full
of holes and the New York Times comes
forward with this report attempting to
shore up the story not by referring to
ramirez's story but by referring to a
secondary incident to an unnamed female
who says she doesn't remember the
incident as reported by a man who says
he reported it to the FBI but won't talk
about it publicly or give any serious
details how are we supposed to take all
that seriously how and the answer is
you're not supposed to take it seriously
you're just supposed to go along with
the Democratic line that Brett Kavanaugh
is actually a rapist and a ritual serial
assaulter and that if you want him on
the Supreme Court or you believe that
there's no evidence to oust him from the
Supreme Court it's because you're a
sexist if Democrats want to play this
game it did not go well for them the
first time we can do it again but I
think this is a pretty box move we'll
see in a second how the 2020 Democrats
are trying to militarize this particular
story we'll get to that in just one
second first you may be walking around
right now listening to this show on a
pair of earbuds and maybe those earbuds
are old fashioned and they have the
wires or they have the stems
maybe they cost you too much money and
you're looking for a second pair of
earbuds that you're not gonna lose and
that look good and sound good well this
is where rake on wireless earbuds come
in rake on earbuds start at about half
the price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as great rate cons a 50 wireless
earbuds have totally changed the game
for me they're incredibly comfortable
they're very easy to take anywhere and
unlike some of your other wireless
options rake on ear buds are both
stylish and discreet they don't have the
dangling wires they don't have the stems
and of course they don't just look great
they sound terrific as well I love my
rake on wireless earbuds you will to
rake on offers they're wireless earbuds
for everyone in a range of fun colors
and an unbeatable price all you have to
do head on over to buy rake on Comm
slash been to get 15% off your order
that's be you IRA Y Co n comm slash been
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you an eye on a pair now would be the
time to get
incredible deal go check him out right
now at by rake hunt calm slash Ben
that's bu IRA Y Co n calm slash Ben by
ray calm calm slash been used that slash
Ben and let them know that we sent you
and also get fifteen percent off your
order okay so the Democratic candidates
jump on this completely unsupported
uncorroborated unspecified story and
they start tweeting a bit out about how
justice Kavanagh should now be impeached
from the Supreme Court now this is all
crap they're never going to get an
impeachment of Cavanaugh it's a thing
that is not going to happen but
Democrats are trying to provide the
false hope to their constituents that if
elected they will impeach Cavanaugh
replace him with somebody on the left
and Phil Ruth Bader Ginsburg seat and
they're trying to re shift the majority
on the Supreme Court in a left-leaning
direction basically by railroad and
Cavanaugh on the basis of non evidence I
will point out one quick thing here
we've had a bevy of public figures in
recent years who have had their
genitalia described on national
television by people who alleged sexual
assault right store McDaniels famously
described president Trump's genitalia
Bill Clinton's genitalia details of such
word talked about nobody has yet
described Cavanaugh's Janet now that's
not dispositive maybe they were generic
who knows but the bottom line is we've
had no corroborating details on any of
these stories all of them apparently
happen in public places with other
witnesses available and not one witness
has been there who corroborates any of
these stories it's unbelievable and yet
the Democrats are still saying that
Cavanaugh should be kicked off the
Supreme Court based on and what a new
report from a guy who says that he was
at a party and saw a mail grab
Cavanaugh's penis which by the way would
be sexual assault and then thrust it
into the hand of a female who says she
doesn't remember the incident it seems
like you might remember that incident
just gonna put that out there but if
you're a female innocently sitting at a
party and suddenly some dude comes and
takes someone else's junk and thrust it
into your hand it feels like that might
be memorable I'm gonna go to the woman
in the room Jess does that seem like a
memorable incident to you it seems like
a memorable incident suggests I will
take just as generic woman here because
I think that that is a fairly memorable
incident I think any normal person would
probably remember that and if called by
the New York Times Oh were you at a
party where someone grab somebody's junk
and thrust it in here seems like it
might be memorable and the New York
Times cutting that and then replacing
that back into the story is really
in say okay so Kamala Harris of course
immediately tweets out that it's time
for Cavanaugh to go it's time for
Cavanaugh to go by the way steyr the
chief executive of a nonpartisan group
in Washington declined to comment on
Sunday but this did not stop the
Democrats so the Democrats started
tweeting out immediately Kamala Harris
says I sat through those hearings Brett
Kavanaugh lied to the US Senate and most
importantly to the American people he
was put on the court through a sham a
process and his place on the court is an
insult to the pursuit of truth and
justice
he must be impeached yeah you sat
through those hearings I remember you
tried to railroad him in those hearings
in fact you brought up Michael a vanadis
allegations that he was engaged in a
chain gang rape as I recall so lady as a
prosecutor as a duly appointed officer
of the court seems to me you don't know
how to lawyer yeah I mean there are a
lot of allegations that she has been
pretty rough in prosecution at least the
people she puts in jail have a jury
trial my god I mean she's out there
saying that he'll I what is their
evidence that he lied does she have any
evidence that he lied of course not all
this is about pandering to the base all
of it is about if I show sufficient
zealousness in pursuit of Brett
Cavanaugh then I'll win a primary it's
really disgusting Elizabeth Warren did
the same thing and Elizabeth Warren
knows better she's a lawyer too she of
course knows better but again Elizabeth
Warren is deeply cynical in the same way
the common law Harris is deeply cynical
Warren's just better at it McConnell
Harris is so cynical that you can see
the the wheels turning in her mind
Katharine Hepburn once described Meryl
Streep as an actress where you could
actually see every wheel turning and she
was transparent you could see all the
gears shifting in her mind when she was
acting a scene well that is the same way
with Kamala Harris Elizabeth Warren is
better at hiding it but she is the same
way she shifted nearly every position
she ever held in order to appeal to the
woke base of the Democratic Party well
now she's doing the same routine she
says last year the Cavanaugh nomination
was rammed through the Senate without a
thorough examination of the allegations
against him while there was an FBI
background check and by thorough
examination of the allegations against
him do you mean like a crapload of
investigation by the Senate and no
corroborating evidence on any of the
massive allegations made against him
like none
Lawrence's confirmation is not
exoneration and these newest revelations
are disturbing I love the reversal of
the burden of proof right there
conformation is not exoneration it's not
your job to exonerate Kavanagh it's your
job to prove not even beyond a
reasonable doubt how about by
preponderance of the evidence he'll how
about by any corroborate of evidence the
cabin odds are this stuff how about that
how about any shred of evidence beyond
just a mere allegation because a mere
allegation ain't enough to get anything
done Warren says like the man who
appointed him Cavanaugh should be
impeached whoo so Trump should be
impeached to see you know that now we
have a bidding war on impeachment
so apparently Cavanaugh should be
impeached and then Trump should be
impeached and then pens should be
impeached and they should probably just
impeach every like Mitch McConnell it's
go for him for good measure but you have
a bidding war Bernie is gonna we impeach
everybody everybody should be impeached
except for me i older men yeah I mean
this is pretty sick stuff they don't
work does the same thing smokes up a do
but he's like brah yesterday we learned
of another accusation against Brett
Kavanaugh when we didn't find out about
before he was confirmed because the
Senate forced the FBI broad to rush its
investigation to save his nomination
we know he lied under oath he should be
impeached no you don't know he lied
under oath you can provide no evidence
that you lied under oath actually I say
I love I love
baito O'Rourke a man who literally
crossed a median barrier while driving
under the influence and hit another car
and then drove away from the scene all
over Brett Kavanaugh because one guy
made an allegation he won't even talk to
the New York Times about who Ian Castro
joined the club he said it's more clear
than ever the Brett Kavanaugh lied under
oath he should be impeached really again
where's the evidence of this any
evidence he's in Congress should review
the failure of the Department of Justice
to properly investigate the matter on
the basis of what the New York Times
corrected its own story to suggest that
the alleged victim in this case does not
recall the incident that there is no
evidence that she even recalls the
incident that this is based on one
uncorroborated allegation by a dude at a
party and there are lots of other people
at the party and there's a victim and
the victim says she doesn't remember it
I mean we went through all of this at
the Times the only new allegation here
is the max tire allegation and that max
tire allegation actually includes
a case of sexual assault not against
Kavanaugh but against the guy who
grabbed his
junk as John as John MacCormack points
out at national review he says can
someone explain the logistics of the
allegation here was Cavanaugh allegedly
walking around naked when his friends
pushed him into the female student he
says no if I'm reading pogrom in and
Kellan row a Kelly right the friends
didn't push cabin on the back rather the
friends pushed his penis this is what
how did that happen who are the friends
who's the female student were there any
witnesses besides steyr is it all that
the authors write in the New York Times
essay about the corroborating is this
mr. Steiner notified senators and the
FBI about the accounts but the FBI
didn't investigate and steyr has
declined to discuss publicly so they
corroborated the fact that Steiner made
the allegation to the FBI but they gave
no indication that they corroborated any
details of the incident
Molly Hemingway who's written her own
book about the railroading of Justice
Kavanagh she wrote on Twitter the book
notes quietly that the woman max steyr
named as having been supposedly
victimized by Kavanagh and Friends
denies any memory of the alleged event
as McCormack says omitting this fact
from the New York Times story is one of
the worst cases of journalistic
malpractice in recent memory he says
even if you take this accusation at face
value that doesn't appear to be an
allegation of assault against Kavanaugh
and if somebody grabs you and throws you
into somebody else you are not actually
the assaulter the person who grabbed you
and threw you into somebody else would
be the person guilty of us all the same
thing would be true here as McCormack
says as I wrote last October here's why
ramirez's allegation was dubious Deborah
Ramirez is the Yale classmate of
Cavanaugh's who now claims Kavanagh
exposed himself at a college freshman as
a college freshman at a party her claim
is already to be us because names
witnesses deny the allegation and
Ramirez herself wasn't sure in recent
weeks if Cavanaugh had done what she now
alleges it doesn't matter all the
matters that the Democrats are calling
for Kavanagh to be impeached which is
really about it's a bunch of nonsense
and President Trump has responded to the
allegations and he is dead right on all
of us we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about going to
the post office now I'll be honest with
you I kind of like the post office but
I'll tell you what I don't like spending
a lot of time in line having to schlep
all my stuff down to the post office to
pain in the butt so instead I save time
and I saved money by using stamps.com
stamps calm brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online
shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
you can simply use your computer to
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready you just hand it's your
mail carrier or you drop it in the
mailbox it is indeed that simple
stamps comb is a no-brainer it saves you
time it saves you money it's no wonder
over 700,000 small businesses already
use stamps calm go check out stamps calm
right now especially because you know
you used to have to go to the grocery
store to get your stamps or go down to
the post office no longer stamps calm
saves you both money because the stamps
are actually that you get deals on
stamps also it saves you all sorts of
time right now my listeners get a
special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that is stamps comm enter
Shapiro go check them out right now okay
so Trump has responded to these
ridiculous allegations against Cavanaugh
he tweeted out now the radical left
Democrats and their partner the
lamestream media are after Brett
Kavanaugh and talking loudly of their
favorite word impeachment he's an
innocent man who's been treated horribly
such lies about him they want to scare
him into turning liberal which by the
way is not wholly untrue okay the fact
is that one of the things that the media
love to do is grant strange new respect
to people who suddenly suddenly begin
interpreting the law according to their
favorite designs John Roberts has been
the recipients of strange new respect in
the past you've seen other Republican
justices Republican appointed justices
justice Stevens for example Justice
Kennedy Corps also hit with the strange
new respect Trump says Brett Kavanaugh
should start suing people for libel or
the Justice Department should come to
his rescue now I'm not sure how the
Justice Department will come to his
rescue politicizing the Justice
Department by having him investigate the
people making the allegations I'm not
sure how that's a federal crime he says
the lies being told about him are
unbelievable that is true he says false
accusations without recrimination when
does it stop they're trying to influence
his opinions can't let that happen
yeah now again that's not really what
they're trying to do it really is not
about influencing Kavanaugh to do their
bidding it really mostly is about making
the false promise to their voters that
they're going to be able to get rid of
Cavanaugh and then replace him with a
leftist Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
in the Senate and wrote the
far-left willingness to cease I'm
completely uncorroborated and
unsubstantiated allegations during last
year's confirmation process was a dark
and embarrassing chapter for the Senate
of course all the 20/20 Democratic
presidential candidates as I mentioned
are now calling for his impeachment
despite the fact that there really is no
evidence that any of this is true Mike
Davis who is chief counsel for Senator
Charles Grassley during the Kavanagh
nomination process said that to the best
of his knowledge Grassley's office had
no record of the allegation he says even
if we did receive an allegation from mr.
steyr as described by the New York Times
reporting it is difficult to see how his
unsubstantiated hearsay quote-unquote
corroborated by anonymous sources
involving an alleged victim who other
unnamed sources said does not even
remember the events would have changed
the outcome of the confirmation vote all
of this is ridiculous and all of it is
politically driven but if Democrats want
to play this game then I guess that they
can play this game now it's interesting
one of the Democrats who did not go here
was Joe Biden and this is because Joe
Biden is smart enough to recognize that
this dog won't hunt in a general
election when Joe Biden seems to be the
only Democrat who seems at all to care
about the general election he seems like
the only person in the Democratic Party
who is even considering what the what
the general election means all the other
Democrats are so busy trying to pander
to the far left of the party that they
are willing to put out their
uncorroborated allegations to target
people without any evidence that
something was done wrong it's pretty
insane and for that trouble Biden is
being ripped of course so Biden's great
scent in the last debate was apparently
that he didn't answer a question about
the legacy of slavery proper but
properly instead he rambled about record
players and education and it was real
weird remember that last week he had
made some suggestions about how
education because poorer kids don't hear
as many words per day they need to have
record players played to them are some
it was very very odd and people pointed
this out and the media have gone after
him for all of this and the media are
really then the media do not want to see
Joe Biden as the nominee because they
feel that he is not radical enough
members of the media are not interested
in Joe Biden Joe Biden is even though he
is pretty radical on policy he's too
moderate for them they want to see a
true visionary they want to see Kamala
Harris a racial visionary or they want
to see Elizabeth Warren a visionary a
socialistic progressive visionary a burn
they don't want anything is boring as a
Biden Trump race that's not what they
want so instead they're going to attack
Biden on the racial issue this is not
this dog is not gonna hunt and I'll
explain why in a second but there's no
question this is where the media are
going an entire CNN panel on Sunday was
devoted to the idea that Joe Biden comes
from the era of racist paternalism that
somehow it's paternalistic to point out
that children of single mothers who are
disproportionately minority might need
some help in the home hey that's not a
race-based thing that's a you only have
one parent there and that does have a
pretty significant impact on the
education of a child but apparently this
is now racist paternalism according to a
CNN panel that he constantly makes these
gaps which are out of touch with where
we are today because he comes from an
era of this like racist paternalism in
public policy making of how we have
looked at dealing with the issues that
the black community faces which frankly
come from racist public policymaking
okay so I'm sorry but not having fathers
in the home does not come from racist
public policy making it does not that is
just silly okay it's silly at this point
in time it did start with that when it
came to slavery when you were forcibly
separating families but the fact is that
more children are now born out of
wedlock in the United States and the
black community than were born out of
wedlock during slavery in the black
community that is not a result of
slavery because you can see these single
motherhood levels declining in the black
community dramatically all the way up to
the 1950s when only 20% of kids born in
black families were born to single
mothers now that number is more like 70%
is that the result of racist
policymaking if so that's a result of
welfare the best case to be made for the
increase in single motherhood in both
the black and white community is that
when the government comes in and pays
you benefits in order not to have a
father in the home that is going to make
it easier for you not to have a father
in the home but apparently if Joe Biden
points out that there are significant
downsides to single motherhood and that
is true cross culturally then this makes
him a racist there's an article in The
Washington Post to this effect today
saying no record players won't solve
inequality is an article by Michal Roz
who is the professor in public policy at
the University of Rochester suggesting
that Joe Biden is in fact racist and
paternalistic because if he points out
an education gap in particular racial
communities then this
is in and of itself racist she says the
mention of the word gap in response to a
question about centuries of American
racism reveals a broader problem while
Biden mentioned redlining and other
racist practices at the beginning of his
answer he ends it with the word gap
itself a paternalistic racist idea well
no a gap is a statistical anomaly okay a
gap is a statistical reality that's
ridiculous if you mentioned the word gap
between two groups of people because
there is an actual statistical gap that
is not racism but the wou cleft is going
to try and portray Joe Biden as a racist
for talking about certain realities on
the ground as we will see this has
become a talking point the Democratic
Party they ain't gonna go anywhere and
I'll explain why in just one second
first let's talk about how you get the
word out about yourself when you go to a
party and somebody asks you for a
business card are you pulling out like
something that you made over at Kinkos
in like 1997 and it's sound cheap paper
and it's printed in health attica font
or something what you really need is a
nice-looking business card it really
does make a difference I get hands at a
lot of business cards and the ones that
tend to make it to my assistants rolodex
are the ones that people have spent time
on they've spent money or the ones that
look the nicest here's the nice thing if
you go to Vistaprint you can get the
ones that look like you spend time and
money on them and you don't have to
spend a fortune your next big
opportunity is coming right now all it
takes to feel like you're ready to own
the now is ten bucks for just ten bucks
vistaprint gives you 500 personalized
cards with exactly the look that you
want that's a low price to make a
lasting impression and because you can
choose the colors and the fonts and the
designs and the images you can create
something as unique and compelling as
your business you can feel good by the
way also knowing that vistaprint uses
carefully selected inks responsibly
sourced paper stocks as well and your
satisfaction is 100% guaranteed or your
money back they'll make it right so I
mean that's a pretty solid deal
Vistaprint wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to vistaprint.com enter
promo code Shapiro's to for free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity limited time offer on the
now at Vista Print com promo code
Shapiro - that is promo code Shapiro
followed by the number two you support
our show when you support our sponsors
go check us out over at vistaprint.com
promo code Shapiro - okay in just one
second we're going to get to the
continued Democratic attack on Joe Biden
as some sort of racial retrograde we'll
get to that in one second it's not real
but
this is the line that's being pushed
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire calm and subscribe when you
do you get the rest of the show live to
get the rest of Andrew Klavan show you
get the rest of Mount Walsh's show you
get the rest of Michael Moses show if
that's something that you want you also
get this the very greatest and beverage
vessels when you get the annual
subscription ooh
look at this thing you could have like
we actually deactivated the cloaking
device just so you could see it today
because we're on the road normally we
cloak it for safety but today since
we're in New York at one of our
beautiful radio studios you can check us
out over at daily wire comm and get one
of these I mean look at this baby it's
fantastic go check that out right now
also when you subscribe you are also
ensuring that we can bring you the
content that you know and love the fact
is that the left wants to silence
opposing voices as you see with Brett
Kavanaugh and they'll go after everyone
and anyone which is why you should go
subscribe right now we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say the rap on Joe Biden is
twofold now one is that he is an
old-style racist who's just covering it
up and the other is that he's really old
he'll get to the old thing in one second
but the old-style racist thing yo Pete
Buddha judge tried to say this yesterday
woke Pete booty dredge who's been having
some pretty significant racial problems
in his home town in South Bend Indiana
where he's mayor he was on CNN and he
suggests Biden gave a really bad answer
on the legacy of slavery so now the way
that you were going to become the
Democratic presidential nominee is we
are going to have you recite from memory
portions of Howard Zinn's a people's
history of the United States a garbage
piece of crap book and if you do it
properly league bait or work then we all
cheer like seals what's so exciting
soapy booty judge did his reading last
night from Howard Zinn and and now he's
very angry at Joe Biden it was a
well-intentioned answer and it was a bad
answer the reason that we are seeing
racial inequity in this country is that
it was put into place on purpose and I'm
not just talking about slavery beginning
400 years ago I'm talking about policy
decisions that happen within living
memory that excluded black Americans
from everything from fully being able to
access the GI Bill to labor protections
these have consequences
okay so again this is gonna be the
Clinton the claim is going to be that
Joe Biden is insufficiently woke on race
there's only one problem who's Barack
Obama's VP for eight years and that goes
a long way Joe Biden gave a big speech
in Birmingham Alabama at a church that
was formally bombed during the civil
rights struggle and here was Biden
talking about racism and talking about
slavery and talking about Barack Obama
we must acknowledge that there can be no
realization of the American dream
without grappling with the original sin
of slavery we have not relegated racism
and white supremacy to the pages of
history but the greatness of this nation
has always been and must continue to be
that we still strive to relegate it okay
so that line by the way is a great line
like I actually agree with Joe Biden
there's there's a gap that is breaking
out in the Democratic Party between Joe
Biden and the rest of the Democratic
Party one is the version of history the
beta overwork is pushing America was
founded in slavery America's
real founding wasn't 1776 it was 1619
and this is the version cheered on by
the New York Times and CNN and then
there's the version that was actually
pushed by Barack Obama right it actually
was yeah I think the Barack Obama was
terrible on a lot of issues but he never
really suggested that America's
foundational principles were rooted in
slavery right his line typically was a
lot more along the lines of what Joe
Biden is saying which is that yes
America has this dark side right there's
there's the other half of the coin but
America has been striving to get rid of
that for years now I will say that I
think Obama's straight into howard zinn
territory affair but too often saying
that racism was written into the
american DNA and all this kind of stuff
but Joe Biden's line here is more
appealing to a mass audience and let's
be real about this Elizabeth Warren
Bernie Sanders Pete Budaj edge these are
all very very white candidates and even
when Kamala Harris tried a racial attack
it turns out that didn't work for her
Cory Booker's been trying it it's not
working why because Joe Biden was Barack
Obama's vice president so I think that
this is unlikely to work on Joe Biden
even the attempts to get Joe bite like
there's an attempt to get Joe Biden
yesterday because he told the story
about facing down a razor wielding gang
leader named corn pop and it was all it
was very weird it was very weird but it
turns out that a leader of the n-double
a-c-p was there and actually says that
the story is true here's Joe Biden
telling a very weird leader a very weird
story about how he was once in a real
life production of West Side Story dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys and I did
yeah and back in those days and sure
things have changed one of the things
had to use if you use pomade in your
hair you had to wear a baby cap and so
he's up on the board wouldn't listen I
said hey Esther you off the board or
I'll come up and drag you off well he
came off and he said I'll meet you
outside she said I'll be waiting for you
wait burns three guys and straight
razors not a joke okay and then he
continues to tell the story people were
all over him for this a leader of the
n-double a-c-p said it was true again I
think that the racial attack on Joe
Biden is unlikely to work so that moves
the Democrats to their secondary attack
and the secondary attack is Joe Biden is
really old so puta judge who is just
smarmy beyond belief he was asked about
Biden's fitness for office on ABC News
as though he's actually relevant and
Buddha judge dodged the question of
course you jumped on one of the
contenders who Leon Castro after you
that inaccurate suggestion that Vice
President Biden didn't remember what he
was saying at the debate but it did
raise all these questions again about
Vice President Biden's age and fitness
for office do you share that concern I
think that's for the voters to decide
look each one of us is competing based
on our abilities and based on our vision
and I think the candidate who has the
best abilities and vision is going to
prevail I think we can lay out the
differences without hitting below the
belt okay except that you refuse to
answer the question but you could just
say is I think Joe Biden's with it if
he's the nominee I'll back him I just
don't think he's the best candidate at
this time right but the Buddha judge
isn't gonna go there again I think that
this attack is probably gonna fall flat
it is all baked into the cake at this
point Plus Joe Biden is a feisty old
stirrer I mean that that is true I mean
he does fall asleep randomly on the
street and he drools sometimes and you
know he likes that early bird dinner at
Denny's but if you ask him certain
questions then he gets kind of feisty a
reporter asked him about being too old
and he threatened to wrestle him
yesterday
medical records the dress compares like
I don't know what tell concerns man you
wanna Russell release my before there's
a first vote ok so again I don't think
that yes he's old yes he's stammering I
don't think that any of this is fatal to
his candidacy now we'll see what the
poll results have to say about the
results from last week's debate but the
other Democrats are increasing that
they're very weak and I think that the
attacks on Biden are particularly weak I
thought that Elizabeth Warren was gonna
rise above the crowd that has not
happened thus far okay now in other news
over the weekend non presidential news
over the weekend the there was a massive
attack on a Saudi oil facility by
allegedly Iran now the reason I say
allegedly Iran is because of Ron denies
it but in reality there's no other force
in the region capable of carrying out
this attack okay the attack was take it
was it was done by drones apparently
provided by Iran to the Houthis in Yemen
or the Iranian backed rebel group in
Yemen according to The Wall Street
Journal Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
blamed Iran for coordinated strikes on
the heart of Saudi Arabia's oil industry
saying they marked an unprecedented
attack
the world's energy supply the strikes
actually shut down half of the kingdom's
crude production on Saturday potentially
roiling petroleum prices and
demonstrating the power of Iran's
proxies around allied Houthi rebels in
neighboring Yemen claimed credit for the
attack saying they sent ten drones to
strike at important facilities in Saudi
Arabia's oil rich eastern province
Pompeyo said that there was actually no
evidence the strikes had come from Yemen
he says they came directly from Iran he
said the United States will work with
allies to ensure that energy markets
remain well supplied and Iran is held
accountable for its aggression he added
that the strikes showed Iran was not
serious about diplomacy which is a major
shift in tone and tenor because there
was a lot of rumor mongering
that President Trump was gonna meet
directly with the Iranian proxy
president Hassan rouhani in person
without preconditions Trump is now
backed off of that Trump is now tweeted
out that it was always fake news that he
was never gonna meet with Hassan rouhani
which it was not okay Mike Pompeo was on
national TV talking about how Trump
might meet with rouhani without
preconditions and there was a lot of
concern in some quarters including my
quarter that the ouster of John Bolton
amounted to president Trump preparing to
make concessions to the Iranians I would
not be surprised in the slightest if the
Iranians saw Bolton's al ster as an
excuse for them to engage in an act of
violence like this to try to intimidate
the Europeans into caving it is exactly
the same behavior that you've seen from
the North Koreans for years is when they
seek to extract the concession from the
West they fire off a bunch of missiles
they do a bunch of nuclear tests and
then they say you know we won't do any
of that if you give us money a rod might
be trying the same thing here also they
are artificially raising the price of
oil
apparently so that the limited supply
can bring more on the open market they
also attack the tanker over the weekend
in the Straits of Hormuz again and the
production shut down amounts to a loss
of about 5.7 million barrels a day the
kingdom's national oil company said
which is roughly five percent of the
world's daily production of crude oil
which is pretty significant officials
said they hoped to restore production to
its regular level of 9.8 million barrels
a day by Monday the energy minister
prince Abdul Aziz bin Solomon said lost
production would be offset through
supplies of oil already on ham se
pledged that there wouldn't be a
dramatic spike in the price of oil
The Wall Street Journal says the strikes
marked the latest in a series of attacks
on the country's petroleum assets in
recent months as tensions rise among
Iran and it's proxies like the Houthis
and the u.s. partners like Saudi Arabia
the attacks could drive up oil prices if
the Saudis can't turn on
their production quickly enough Trump
called Saudi Arabia's day-to-day ruler
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman on
Saturday he said the US was ready to
cooperate with the kingdom in supporting
its security and stability and of course
as I say the attacks happened a few days
before world leaders are set to gather
in New York for the UN General Assembly
the Iranians presumably will attempt to
claim that it is Trump's pressure and
exit from the Iran ziyal that have
provoked all of this naturally the left
in American foreign policy will agree
with that because I always blame America
first you always got to make it about
America being the the Agent Provocateur
in the Middle East despite the fact that
Iran has been engaged in widespread
terror campaigns for at least the last
four decades Saturday's attack was the
largest yet claimed by the Houthis in
terms of its overall impact on the Saudi
economy Fabien hen's is an arms
researcher at the Middlebury Institute
of International Studies in Monterey
California said the attack has been
quite surprising he says we've seen
quite a few drone and missile attacks
against Saudi infrastructure in most
cases the actual damage has been quite
minimal even before Pompeo tweeted about
it analysts caution against accepting
the Houthi claim that they are the ones
who did it as opposed to the Iranians
directly Iran of course is denying and
then they say they're ready for war with
the United States so it's an
intimidation tactic is what this most
looks like an intimidation tactic by
Iran in an attempt to extract
concessions from Europe and the United
States to drive a wedge between Europe
and the United States with regard to
Iran if by the way this does create that
effect if what you see here is the
Europeans siding with the Iranians it
just shows the cowardice of the
Europeans because it's perfectly obvious
what the Iranians are doing here do you
really trust a country that is bombing
Saudi oil facilities to keep its
commitments if we just sign them some
cash or do you think that probably
they're gonna keep funding all of the
groups that are funding before accept an
elevated fashion according to The Wall
Street Journal this is the big one they
call this the big one they said the
technical sophistication and audacity of
Saturday's attack will linger over the
energy market well the the truth is that
this could have some pretty significant
impact on world markets generally and
how we allocate resources to protect
those markets and yes we are still
dependent enough on oil that we should
be protecting against Iranian attacks on
Saudi Arabia just the way that we
protected against Saddam Hussein
invading Kuwait and said attempting to
invade Saudi Arabia back in the first
Gulf War
the limited goal of protecting America's
oil supply that does have a massive
impact on the global economy and
allowing Iran concessions so that Iran
can go forward and participate in terror
is an insane insane policy and yet I
think that what you're seeing is the is
the Trump administration come around to
that Iran ironically actually just cut
in favor of John Bolton's position with
their increased violence there's one
thing that Trump doesn't like and that's
being pushed into a corner nobody pushes
baby into a corner now President Trump
is not interested in being pushed around
by the Iranians their best move here
would have been to keep quiet just the
way that the North Koreans were keeping
quiet for a while and then try to engage
in personal diplomacy with President
Trump but apparently they needed cover
with their own people for any sort of
meeting right there there are a lot of
analysts today who are suggesting that
basically Iran engaged in these acts of
violence so that they can then engage in
negotiations while telling their
domestic audience that they are standing
up to the United States but there's one
problem
Trump ain't gonna sit down if you're
punching him in the face at the same
time president Trump does not like being
humiliated on the public stage and he
sees this as an attack on his prestige
and on his and on his willingness to
take a strong stance this is a pretty
major mistake I think by the Iranians
meanwhile over in Israel it is 48 hours
to the Israeli election the media are
doing their damnedest to get rid of
Benjamin Netanyahu they're trying to
claim that Netanyahu was a fascist he
has not he's been elected a bajillion
times he is not in any way encroached on
democracy in the State of Israel the
media continue to operate fully and
freely and openly there's a long article
a terrible article in The Washington
Post today suggesting that Israel as
part of the decline of liberal order
which is insane Israel is the only
liberal country in the Middle East the
the contention is that because Israel is
trying to navigate the world of
international politics by making friends
with illiberal states like Saudi Arabia
and Hungary that somehow this amounts to
Netanyahu giving in to fascism well why
don't you provide them an alternative by
let's say France not being anti-semitic
or Germany not being anti-semitic or
Britain not making away from Jeremy
Corbyn you know it's a really easy way
for Israel to be more Pro France for it
from France view more pro-israel it
turns out that Israel has a pretty
obvious agenda here and that's its own
survival but apparently according to the
media that's how the bounds they're
gonna be very surprised honestly the
media are gonna be super surprised if
blue and white
which is the rival party to newton yahoo
in israel if blue and white is elected
and they somehow form a coalition which
looks doubtful in the lead-up to this
election it looks like by latest polling
in Yahoo still has enough for a
coalition which is unbelievable the
guy's an incredible blue just on a
political level you have to admire the
guy with that said if blue and white
were to take over call the LaVon what
you would see is actually them mirror
Netanyahu's exact foreign policy that
foreign policy is not changing why
because the on-the-ground conditions
have not changed in fact you know who
supports the idea of extending Israeli
sovereignty over some of the Jordan
Valley
Kovalev on the exact party that the left
is trying to uphold now you want to know
why the left really opposes Netanyahu
the hard left because it's yeah who's
just a proxy for Israel that's it and if
blue and white were to take over they
would feel the same way because any
party in Israel that refuses to make
concessions to terrorists will be seen
as the problem the person who makes this
clearest of course is brutal anti-semite
Ilhan Omar who can't go more than 35
seconds without shouting about the Jews
well she was on Face the Nation because
we have to pretend she's a legitimate
political figure I'm like Steve King who
is not a legitimate political figure
Ilhan Omar who is a bigot is on Face the
Nation talking about her wonderful grand
plans for the country while she talked
on Face the Nation about Netanyahu she
said Netanyahu's existence his existence
was a threat to peace you know not come
off a terrorist group that fires
missiles into the center of Israel not
Hezbollah a terrorist group that fires
rockets into northern Israel not Islamic
Jihad a terrorist group that is part of
a coalition government not the
Palestinian Authority which pays the
families of terrorists Benjamin
Netanyahu the duly elected leader of
Israel isn't his existence his very
breathing is a threat to Middle Eastern
peace according to rabid anti-semite
ohan Omar do you stand by your call for
a boycott of Israel
I certainly hope that the people of
Israel make a different decision and my
hope is that they recognize that his
existence his policies his rhetoric
really is contradictory to the peace
that we are all hoping that that region
receives and receives soon okay so um
that would be a yes I'm continuing to
call for Israel's boycott does anyone
truly think that Omar is suddenly gonna
call off her desire for a boycott if
Netanyahu is no longer Prime Minister
what absolute garbage what absolute
nonsense Netanyahu again is great at
domestic politics I love when there's
international scrutiny on domestic
political infighting in a full-on
democracy it's oh it's always very
entertaining to me there's never any
sort of scrutiny on you know the actual
ruling coalition in the Palestinian
Authority Mahmoud Abbas is currently in
the let's see thirteenth year of a
four-year term have you seen any
scrutiny about that at all there's a
story today about the Turkish government
claiming that Israel's in apartheid
state oh you mean the radical
dictatorship in Turkey that supports
come off the media's coverage of Israel
is always wild and insane and biased the
fact is there is wide consensus in
Israeli society on foreign policy and I
think the world will be shocked to learn
that that consensus is not driven in
fact by Bibi Netanyahu and his cruel
cruel view of the world it's driven by
actual circumstance namely that the
supposed partners in peace over there
are actual terrorists okay coming up
we'll do a quick thing I like and then
we'll do some things that I hate so
things that I like so my boy Andrew gang
I thought said something that was quite
classy over the weekend so Andrew yang
was asked about this guy who was on SNL
and the this this person on SNL
apparently in some old tape he used some
racial slurs about Asians and he
suggested that he made some some racist
jokes about the Chinese according to the
New York Times he made racist remarks
mocking Chinese people used a racial
slur in a podcast episode last year he
then apologized on Twitter for it
apparently the conversation began with a
discussion about Chinatown and Gillis
said I'd like to go down there and be
like what are you guys doing here get
those ducks out of that window and then
later Gilles mocked a Chinese boy who
described as practicing
said we had to move tables it was so
annoying that's more annoying than any
other minority playing music at a
restaurant loud on their phone and then
he said nice racism like walking it back
and make me joke about his own racial
joke ok so then he apologized for it and
everyone went nuts should he be fired
should he lose his job because no one
has ever told a racially tinged joking
comedy no one's ever done anything like
that you mean professional comedians
tell racially tinged joke by the way
Dave Chappelle's getting all sorts of
flack for his latest comedy special
because of his words on on Lok social
justice warriors half of the special
isn't about how he doesn't care about
white people dying on streets of heroin
overdoses ok
so people are making comedy jokes about
race all the time as he's unser
so racial jokes are only OK when they're
directed one way apparently but this is
why again I think Andrew yang may be the
only like nice person running for
presidents of the United States so I
call my boy Andrew gang who came on my
Sunday special and actually is a nice
person whom I have met and is a human
being so he was asked about this by Jake
Tapper and he said you know we could use
in the society maybe like a little
forgiveness there's been a number of
reactions to my call for forgiving Shane
Gillis and I've experienced a lot of
anti Asian racism throughout my
upbringing and it hurts but at the same
time bigger picture I believe that our
country has become excessively punitive
and vindictive about remarks that people
find offensive or racist and that we
need to to try and move beyond that if
we can particularly in a case where the
person you know is in this case to me
like a comedian whose words should be
taken in a slightly different light
wouldn't you rather live in Andrew
Yang's world than live in the Volks cold
world where somebody uncovers a comment
from 15 years ago or 30 years ago or 50
years ago and you've changed and you've
apologized and said I mean really look
good for Andrew yang good friend really
I know that sound members of the of the
social democrat base the same people who
say the joe biden is a vicious racist
but good for Andrew yang that is a good
thing we need more of that in our
society and frankly more of that from
both sides of the aisle okay time for a
quick thing that I hate
so last week you'll recall there's a big
controversy that broke out over an ad
that ran during the democratic debate in
particular markets it was an ad from a
group as having is called new minority
PAC and it was a it was an ad directed
against socialism by a Cambodian woman
and this is the ad looked something like
that sounded something like this this is
the face of socialism and ignorance does
Alexandra Ocasio Cortese know the horror
of socialism
my father was minutes from death in
Cambodia before a forced marriage saved
his life that's socialism forced
obedience starvation mine is a face of
freedom my skin is not white his name is
Elizabeth Harris and these name of the
group is new GOP faces super PAC that
lady's name Elizabeth hang and she got
all sorts of flack for this now again
it's a very hard-hitting ad I'm not sure
I love the image of a o'seas face being
burned away but but it really is not
about violence against AOC the ad the ad
is about how she doesn't understand
socialism so the media of course took
this to mean that this was calling aoc
Pol Pot no this is not calling aoc Pol
Pot this is saying I mean the ad
literally says she doesn't understand
the effects of actual Marxist socialism
so Chris Cuomo who is a block of wood on
CNN yeah we were not allowed to call him
Fredo so he won't call him Fredo we will
never ever call him Fredo it's a racial
slur apparently for Italians which Chris
Cuomo discovered like three weeks ago
but we will never ever call him Fredo so
here's Chris here's not Fredo
who is talking on Siena and with
Elizabeth hang explaining that Pol Pot's
regime wasn't about socialism which is
really interesting because it was
totally about socialism you are so well
educated you know that you know you can
talk about socialism any way you want
Pol Pot was a brutal autocrat and
dictator that wasn't about socialism
that was about him being an evil human
being you know you can go to Scandinavia
or Denmark and see socialism they're not
killing people all right no that is no
no no no if you go to Denmark or you go
to Scandinavia what you're actually not
seeing is socialism you're seeing a
social safety net based on a capitalist
economy in which free-market economics
works and most ownership of goods and
services is in private
if you want to look at full-scale
government top-down socialism it does
look like Pol Pot every time is tried if
you talk about full government
nationalization of resources it looks
like Cuba
it looks like Venezuela it looks like
the USSR it looks like Pol Pot now you
can make the argument that AOC isn't for
full-scale government nationalization of
these industries the problem is that you
keep saying she's for nationalization of
all industries now there's a there's a
very famous joke about Winston Churchill
talking to Clement Attlee and the two of
them are going to the they're going to
the urinal together and Clement Attlee
looks over and and Churchill sort of
shied away and Clement Attlee says what
are we embarrassed Winston and Winston
looks back and says no Clements it's
just that every time you see something
large you want to nationalize it oh that
that is the that is the view of when it
comes to major American industries Chris
Cuomo suggesting that Pol Pot has
nothing to do with socialism is absurd
it's absurd I mean it's like saying that
that that Hitler's Nazism had nothing to
do with big government it was actually a
libertarian movement like that is
absolute sheer nonsense and then Chris
Cuomo does super big journalism in its
journalism in time for quiz coamo here's
Chris Cuomo explaining that it's not
just that Pol Pot isn't a socialist it's
that Elizabeth hang this pro Trump
Republican woman she's misdirecting her
oxd about socialism she should actually
be angry at Trump so here's Chris Cuomo
explaining as an objective journalist
that someone with a different viewpoint
should to believe like he does as an
objective journalist who hates Trump you
know I get that you want to make
political points with this but you know
people like your family and what you
represent which again I believe is part
of the blessing of this country your
fight is with the president that you
support he's the one who talks about
people like your parents like there's
some other that shouldn't be in this
country because they came here with
nothing except the hope in their heart
and wanting to make it he doesn't want
those people in this country now AOC
isn't your enemy you can go after her
policies he'd say they don't capitalist
society but if you may not believe it
but it's the truth Elizabeth he's the
one who's going okay no is not the truth
it is your opinion okay Chris Cuomo
declaring that what he believes his
opinion is the truth so his opinion is
Pol Pot wasn't a socialist which is
absolute crap it's a historic nonsense
he's a self stated Marxist Leninist who
attempted to
Tonie marxist-leninist and Leninist
regime from above so much so that he
wanted the flag of Cambodia which looked
like a checkered flag as the logo of his
party he actually forced land
redistribution so that photos from above
looked like the flag so they were
perfectly equal squares looking like a
checkerboard okay that that is how
doctrinaire Pol Pot was in his Marxism
and Leninism and then he follows that up
with also you should hate Trump because
Trump wouldn't let your parents in is
there any evidence that Trump would not
let in the Vietnamese boat people like
really is there is there a lot of
evidence of that because I'm not
particularly seeing that evidence maybe
you'd want them vetted as far as humanly
possible for safety precautions but I've
seen no evidence that Trump would have
rejected the Vietnamese boat people who
are attempting to escape or Cambodians
attempting to escape the Cambodian
genocide or people who are coming here
legally and not illegally that's pretty
pretty wild stuff there from Chris Cuomo
again our media just outdoing themselves
day in and day out brilliant brilliant
stuff alrighty well we will be back here
later with two additional hours of
content or we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jessica all Vera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]